here's Klaus Schwab I know you guys like
Klaus Schwab you know Klaus Schwab from
the world economic Forum who's right out
of like Hollywood 101 the evil guy uh he
seemingly is running half of the world
right now and uh even though fauci can't
figure out why China would want these
lockdowns
um I think Schwab is kind of onto
something and understands maybe why
China would do this and perhaps we could
extrapolate that and send it across the
globe on the G20 you were there meeting
some of the leaders as well Professor
schwaba what do you make up the result
finally they put something as a
statement and it seems quite positive
with all the voices included I think
it's positive it's already positive so
the fact that everybody agreed about the
statement which we haven't had the last
years now surveys has been formed but
um we have to go one step further we
have to have a strategic mood we have to
construct the World of Tomorrow it's a
systemic transformation of the world so
we have to Define
how the world should look like which we
want to come out of this transformation
period
I
respect China's
achievements which are tremendous over
the last over 40 years I think it's a
role model for many countries but I
think also
we should leave it to each country
to make its own decision what system it
wants to adapt and I think we should be
very careful in imposing systems but the
Chinese model is certainly a very
attractive model for her quite an
abortion okay so he's speaking out of
both sides of his mouth there you see
what he did at the end right he's
running something called the world
economic Forum he brings in all these
world leaders and then through ESG
scores and everything else they figure
out ways to manipulate their people
right and they figure out ways to
silence dissent and everything that
happened in Canada and Australia et
cetera et cetera so on one hand he's
like but I believe in Sovereign Nations
and everyone can do what they want but
China's done a really hell of a job here
so even though fauci from the clip
before fauci has no idea why they would
do these Draconian lockdowns yeah he
doesn't know why China would do it why
would you have that zero policy related
to covid but Klaus Schwab is telling you
why because you want a as he said we
want to construct the World of Tomorrow
we want a systemic transformation of the
world these people are doing it in plain
sight so while Klaus Schwab is very he
has very nice things to say about the
last 40 Years of China sure they've
completely silenced dissent you know
individual rights aren't respected as I
said they're literally locking people in
apartment buildings and people are star
carving to that in their Apartments